ELIF BONCUK: Hi, my name's Elif.
I work as a software specialist
at Garanti Technology Mobile
Applications team.
iGaranti and Cep
[? Subesi, ?] which
are our most popular
banking applications,
are our team's products.
There are lots of different
devices in the market with lots
of different capabilities.
Because of being a bank,
we should provide service
to all of our customers.
And some of the devices
have some low memory issues.
"Don't keep activities" options,
which is lying under developer
options, gives us the
opportunity of assimilating
these low memory issues.
Today I'm going to tell you
the most important and common
low memory issue, which is
your activities being created.
The system may
destroy your activity
if it's stopped, or hasn't
been used for a long time,
or the foreground's activity
needs more resources.
So, the system will destroy your
activity to recover the memory.
Let's think about money
transfer transaction.
There are lots of selections in
the page-- [INAUDIBLE] account,
branch selection.
If a low memory issue happens
on the user selection page--
let's say account selection--
the user selects the account
and turns back to the main page.
And because of low memory,
all the selections,
all the fields will be cleared.
If your activity stops
because of a low memory issue,
then a save instance statement
will be called by the system.
And you can save all your data--
what you want-- in this method.
And after recreating
your activity,
the Restore Instant Statement
[INAUDIBLE] will be called.
So, you can restore back
all your data in here,
and the system uses [? model ?]
[? objects ?] in this solution.
The official solution
wasn't enough in our case,
because being we created
[INAUDIBLE] activity
means to us, the users start
transaction from main start
and select all the
selections again and again.
And of course, we could
use on-service statement
[INAUDIBLE] and
official solution.
But it would miss
high cost [INAUDIBLE]
assimilated to problem and
develop another solution.
If you use one activity
for a whole transaction
and a fragment for
each related page,
then your activity
won't be recreated,
and you will complete your
transaction in one activity.
If you want to solve the
foreground/background canvas,
you can use custom components,
on-service [INAUDIBLE],
activities on-service
[INAUDIBLE].
And you can save all the data.
But if you think
about your users--
users in other application
or at another transaction--
it's not a very good problem
to lose the data which
is not using one.
One last issue I
want to talk about
is our bundle object, which you
use for saving data and passing
data between activities.
Bundle object has a
maximum storage limit.
And if you have to keep more
than this maximum limit,
then you have to develop
some other solutions.
In that case, you want to use
your device's local storage,
maybe.
But it won't be a safe solution.
Our solution is,
in that case, use
a hash map that will allow
[INAUDIBLE] our application.
I'll talk about the
common low memory issue
and how we solve it.
My advice to all
Android developers--
select this option
before submission
and control their applications.
They don't have to solve
every low memory issue.
But at least they could known
which problems the users
are faced with.
[MUSIC PLAYING]